move office good afternoon to everybody
ha sir jajajaja yo friend just as soon
as you run of algerian origin if you saw
a muslim faith I'm going on throughout
we called Ahmed Mira bear represent the
French police and to defend the values
of the Republic freedom equality
fraternity I thought lashauwn you hope
to neutral thanks to his determination
he became a judicial police officer to
patrol and he was going to be leaving
the country soon to come on his country
some companions described him as being
somebody who loved his job imed oh my
gosh more he was committed I mean I've
wanted this or some ammo Alicia he
looked after his mother and his closest
family since his father died 20 years
ago he was a pillar of the family no
Shabbat mapa super and his
responsibilities his work still meant
that he was a very protective father a
lovely brother a very spoiling uncle who
was the Box reflector barber and a
loving companion devastated by this bub
barakat we are devastated for all the
victims from at law I now I'm addressing
myself to all racists the azan
islamophobes and the anti-semites
confirming oh geez you mustn't mix-up
extremism with muslims live all the
madmen have no color nor religion
Charles would rock opera and I just like
to underline another a sport like yo
stop associating having walls or burning
mosques and burning synagogue so because
you're attacking people some are madhab
on walk it won't bring back the bear the
dead and it won't comfort the families
thank you